hi there today i'm going to talk about
whether some languages are easier than
others i often get asked the question
here at youtube and elsewhere
which is easier language a or language b
or
variations on that like how long will it
take me to learn
spanish or chinese or
or a language
and
the answer to the first question is yes
some languages are easier than others
very much so
it all depends on which languages you
know
how motivated you are the availability
of interesting content there's so many
things that affect it i'll give you an
example i started korean
before i started russian czech
ukrainian not to mention romanian which
i only did for two months
i spent six months on korean before we
had
korean at linc
and listing an hour an hour and a half a
day going through you know
teach yourself and and i bought lots of
korean books uh
ross king's very good book from ubc and
so forth and so on
um and then i went through another
period with korean
uh and i've been doing a lot of of uh
korean at link
there's no question that i understand
russian and i listen to russian i
understand 95
czech 85 ukraine and 85
even romanian which i only spent two
months on i understand much better than
korean why
number of reasons first of all
once i had invested all that time in
russian and i put a lot more time into
russia than i put into korean
but once i had done that then of course
the check became easier and the
ukrainian became easier and i've looked
at polish i've started a bit of polish
it will be a piece of cake after
ukrainian
romanian
70 of the words are so similar to
italian it's written in the same
alphabet it sounds similar the
vocabulary is very similar similar and
the other 20 percent has slavic roots so
it's it's similar
korean even though it has 50 vocabulary
of chinese origin it's not immediately
obvious what those chinese words are
because it's pronounced so differently
a number of things make it difficult but
the other thing is
uh that not only is it therefore
intrinsically more difficult for
someone of my language background even
though i speak chinese and japanese so
it should be easier for me in fact it
probably is easier for me than someone
who has no experience in asian languages
but the other thing is
my motivation or the the kind of content
that i can find
i have with my uh
with my russian i found not only
audiobooks of tolstoy and stuff with
texts available online echo must
with the check there was so much
interesting content the ukrainian i'm
following the events listening to uh
podcasts from from ukraine and so forth
and so on
korean i really
the interesting material that i have
found is very difficult
uh the easy stuff is of no interest to
me
so and there hasn't been any sort of
urgency or
anything that's driving me towards it
now i'm going to visit korea in march
and perhaps that'll perhaps that'll turn
things around so to summarize
yes some languages are definitely easier
than others it depends on which
languages you already know it depends on
your motivation your opportunity
uh what other stimulus there might be
there's so many factors that affect it
and therefore to even say how long it
takes to learn a language to me it's
a very difficult thing to say and for
that matter the related question on you
know which language should i learn
i can't tell you that it's entirely up
to your individual
situation
thank you for listening bye for now